bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés les
examens à peine terminée par le temps de
souffler pour les étudiants une nouvelle
étape importante se profile pour eux se
loger un véritable casse-tête
généralement entre difficultés
administratives d'organisation encore
financière pour la plupart pourtant vous
allez le voir des solutions existent et
elles sont nombreuses et notamment à
saint quentin en yvelines pour en parler
quatre invités avec moi ce soir laurence
cousin la directrice d'yveline
information jeunesse pour la 2 berly
directrice de l'habitat pour saint
quentin en yvelines
denis jézégou responsable de l'agencé
chevaleret pour espace si les et
isabelle etienne chargé de mission
yvelines pour ensemble2générations
bonsoir à tous les quatre on le sait
c'est souvent très compliqué de se loger
quand on est étudiant ne connaît pas
forcément toutes les démarches à faire
on est parfois loin de chez soi on a peu
ou pas d'argent et le manque de
logements peu vite effrayer poussé à
faire n'importe quoi alors ça c'est pour
la partie très souple dutra du tableau
vous allez nous rassurer tout de suite
on va commencer avec vous lors aux
cousins on va le dire tout de suite à
ceux qui nous regardent qui nous
écoutent avec un peu d'organisation un
peu de savoir-faire et de méthodes tout
le monde aura un logement d'ici le mois
de septembre
oui on va était optimiste effectivement
à partir du moment où on était organisée
qu'on s'y prend suffisamment tôt ne peut
trouver un logement bien noté alors on
est là à fin juin les examens seront
terminés ce qu'on rentre dans la période
un petit peu compliqué ce qu'on a encore
un peu de temps est ce qu'il faut il
faut s'activer et immédiatement pour les
est la bonne période pour commencer à
à faire les démarches notamment nathan
souvent des réponses pour les étudiants
de l'année à venir
donc c'est le moment où on commence à se
positionner sur un sur un logement alors
ceux qui n'ont pas encore commencé leur
démarche est ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer quels sont le premier réflexe
à avoir quand on commence 2 0 qu'est ce
qu'on doit faire
la première fois d'ailleurs quand on est
étudiant il ya le fameux ds le dossier
social étudiant où on invite les
étudiants à se positionner sur des
résidences universitaires pour celui qui
font le choix des résidences
universitaires publics et à la fois
aussi une demande de bourses puisqu'il
ya une double demande donc là il ya un
calendrier à respecter puisque de
mémoire c'est fin avril à la deadline
pour exprimer ses voeux donc c'est déjà
en amont oui les jeux annoncés déjà
avoir fait en amont des démarches
apprennent moi je représente le réseau
information jeunesse au niveau des
yvelines vont voir mais voilà pour ceux
qui viennent en province qui viennent
étudier sur la région parisienne il ya
un réseau national ya plus de 2400
structure information jeunesse nous sur
le département des yvelines on édite un
guide qui s'appelle se loger ou tous les
tous les jeunes qu'ils soient étudiants
ou qu'ils aient un autre statut
on les informations sur les dispositifs
existants et les possibilités
d'hébergement sur sur le département
mais ceux qui souhaitent se déplacer
pour venir vous voir vous êtes ici pas
très loin exactement depuis janvier 2016
on est trois parties des sources à
montigny le bretonneux jeunesse pour
l'adouber relie c est ce que c'est
encore possible aujourd'hui de se loger
dans le parc public avec le crous ou
alors maintenant si on cherche des
logements maintenant il faut cibler le
secteur privé non pas du tout
aujourd'hui on a alors sur saint quentin
en yvelines faut savoir qu on a doublé
les capacités au niveau des logements
étudiants depuis deux trois ans avec
avec des livraisons qui ont eu lieu
notamment l'année dernière 300 logements
étudiants sur la résidence du vélodrome
une résidence jeunes actifs qui a été
ouvert ses portes également septembre
dernier de 183 logements et qui
s'adresse notamment aux apprentis ou
jeunes actifs
et puis concernant cette année
particulièrement on à la résidence de la
verrière qui est une résidente donkey et
à tarif social et qui aujourd'hui encore
des disponibilités puisqu'elle va ouvrir
ses portes au mois de septembre mais il
ya encore des disponibilités puis après
il ya le taux de rotation
naturelle d'un certain nombre de
résidences étudiantes qui situent
notamment ils encourent on à rené cassin
et l'encours sur lesquels on a eu un
certain nombre de départs d'étudiants et
sur le cahier des possibilités donc pour
ça il faut savoir que la communauté
d'agglomération à ce qu'on appelle des
droits de réservation cirque on a la
possibilité nous positionner directement
des candidats il ya un numéro de
téléphone qui peut être rappeler qui est
le 01 39 44 81 42
là dessus on vous orientera vers un site
une adresse mail qui est donc étudiants
@ est-ce qu y point fr sur lesquels vous
pouvez faire des demandes et donc il ya
encore des possibilités donc pas de
panique on a lors du dernier forum
étudiant samedi on a encore des parents
qui sont venus et des étudiants on l'a
rarement les a rassurés là dessus à 50
ans il ya environ dix mille étudiants
oui combien de logements alors
disponibles pour ces étudiants là
globalement sur la totalité de l'offre
sociales crous et privé on est à plus de
2300 35 logements étudiants en y
incluant la future résidence qui va
ouvrir ses portes pas très loin d'ici
action 47 classes l'année prochaine et
concernant les jeunes actifs donc y
compris les apprentis on va arriver à un
total de plus de 734 logement en y
incluant de livraison qui vont arriver
en 2017 sur l'arrêt sur la ville de
voisins-le-bretonneux avec son logement
jeunes actifs et sur elancourt sans
logement également sur la clé
saint-pierre donc une offre qui se
développe à la fois pour les jeunes
apprentis et jeunes actifs et pour les
étudiants et vous le disions peu on peut
vous appeler puis il ya un site internet
aussi il rassemble toutes ces
informations là de fait alors il ya un
guide également mais il ya surtout sur
l'agglo le site de l'agglo vous avez les
infos pratiques et avec ce guide qui est
à 10 pays l'une des grosses inquiétudes
on le sait quand on veut ce logement les
étudiants c'est forcément le coup le
loyer
la bonne nouvelle il ya des aides
évidemment on va commencer par l'une
d'entre elles peut être la plus connue
laurence cousin vous qui avez la forme à
l'habitude d'informer les jeunes là
dessus l'apl tout le monde est éligible
à l'appel alors là effectivement ça
dépend effectivement du profil du jeune
de ses ressources etc
le plus simple c'est effectivement les
diriger sur le site de la caf parce que
l'ajustement la caf a bien bien
redéployer le site internet que ce soit
d'ailleurs on affine on a fait comme on
dirait
une réunion de professionnels
information jeunesse avec la caf y pour
justement être vraiment dans la
possibilité d'accompagner au mieux les
jeunes sur les différents dispositifs et
le logement en fait partie peut faire
des simulations ce qui leur permette
vraiment d'anticiper sur le budget
logement à venir sont que l'appel c'est
l'aide personnelle au logement louis a
aussi peut-être moins connus là elle est
là et voilà exactement là c'est pareil
vous avez d'une petite déclinaison
inquiets dans le guide qui permet de
voir un petit peu à kaka quelle
population de s'adressent les
différentes aides et le plus simple là
pour le coup c'est d'aller sur le site
internet et de faire une simulation en
ligne
on continue sur ces aides rapidement
avec celle qui nous permettent de payer
la caution ça peut être un problème est
aussi d'avoir des gars en on a le
loca-pass tout à fait et puis on a la
clé la caution locative étudiante un mot
aussi sur ces aides la belle halle
intéressés fait effectivement c'est de
pouvoir permettre au plus grand nombre
d'accéder d'accéder à un logement parce
qu on sait qu effectivement la garantie
même pour les adultes c'est quelquefois
très très compliqué compliqué d'avoir un
garant donc là l'idée c'est que
effectivement il ya un dispositif qui
permette d'avancer alors pas porte le
nom il faut bien vérifier qu'on soit
éligible
mme hedegaard d'avancé 7 cette garantie
et ses garanties là est ce que tous ces
dispositifs lasson sont connus
aujourd'hui des étudiants est ce qu'il
ya un manque d'information
est-ce que c'est simple d'en bénéficier
concrètement alors concrètement c'est
vrai que tout ne l'ait pas informé mais
c'est justement l'intérêt de pouvoir
être informer accompagner alors je vais
faire la promotion du réseau information
jeunesse qu'est ce qu'on est vraiment là
pour ça et après on va leur donner soit
les partenaires référence d'une option
de la table est la thématique du
logement on connaît très très bien tous
les partenaires quels qu'ils soient que
ce soit le claj l'adil pour les spas les
questions juridiques
ensemble2générations et enfin voilà et
donc on est en capacité puisqu'on on
s'adapte à la demande du jeune con en
face de nous de le diriger vers les deux
interlocuteurs
denis jézégou vous c'est les résidences
privées est ce qu'on a le droit à ces
aides là quand on vient se loger chez
vous par exemple pour compléter ce que
madame dit on va en effet une autre
mission à nous c'est de guider
il est de proposer ce qui peut le
profitez donc évidemment nous aussi on
pratique la peine ce qui est quand même
hyper intéressant parce que on sait très
bien que un étudiant si les six sur ses
ressources a aidé moins deux îles et il
n'y a pas il n'a pas travaillé il a pas
eu de revenus le bon c'est le taux
d'appel est quand même maximum donc
c'est extrêmement intéressant
nous on le pratique sur l'ensemble de
nos résidences il est vrai que c'est
c'est très bien cette aide parce que ça
va dans le sens de logements temporaires
que nous faisons nous c'est à dire la
première année généralement vous avez un
taux maximum d'après la deuxième année
un peu moins parce qu'entre temps le
locataire a pu travailler et ainsi de
suite
d'envié c'est aussi un cheminement qui
fait que ça participe au parcours
locatif les résidences privées et il y
en a une qui va ouvrir de votre groupe
bientôt à montigny combien faut compter
pour se loger
par exemple chez vous c'est vrai que
souvent on dit le privé et puis c'est
vrai c'est plus cher est ce que c'est
excessivement cher ou alors est-ce que
ça abordable alors c'est vrai qu'en fait
vie privée vous l'avez dit deux fois
espacil habitat c'est une entreprise
privée mais qui fait de logement social
et qui a une règle éthique tout à fait
détendue large et qui pratiquent en
l'espèce sur montigny qui comme vous
l'avez dit est une résidence tout à fait
particulière parce que dans le groupe
est facile c'est la seule qui est
complètement dédié ses 154 logements
sont en totalité dédiés à des doctorants
des post doctorants et des chercheurs
donc c'est quand même déjà un niveau
d'étude que tout le monde atteint pas tu
peux me permettre
les tarifs que j'écris sous les yeux
pour que j'ai sous les yeux peut pas
faire d'erreur vont de 410 euros à 836
euros
c'est à dire en gros les premières
surface et 22 22 22 mètres carrés et les
plus grandes surfaces 55 mètres carrés
les typologies t1 t1bis t2 donc alors ce
sont des prix qui sont hors apl alors en
fonction des ressources à une
main-d'oeuvre vous pouvez avoir des
résiduelles qui sont 2
150 euros c'est quoi la vente âge d'être
en résidences privées c'est peut-être
d'avoir un confort supérieur d'avoir des
appartements au mieux équiper davantage
il n'est pas lié forcément ah au fait
que nous soyons une entreprise privée
c'est surtout lié à la qualité du
produit que se passe-t-il construit et
c'est vrai que pour ceux qui ont connu
les les foyers à l'ancienne avec des
parties communes partagées cuisine
sanitaires etc
on n'est plus dans ce genre de coup sûr
été un peu l'image généralement de vos
besoins clients très précaire du coup
aujourd'hui mais j'espère que quand la
résidence sera ouverte à partir du point
de début septembre vous viendrez sur
place visite et la qualité du produit et
surtout poser des questions aux jeunes
qui s'installent et voir le plaisir
qu'ils ont à s'installer dans une
résidence qui non seulement est tout
neuf dans première occupation dans un
bâtiment neuf c'est quand même de la
qualité pour des prix qui restent quand
même hyper raisonnable avec une qualité
de prestation qui est s'en vanter
espacil habitat qui est quand même de la
très belle prestation
isabelle etienne avant de vous donner la
parole paul albert lee combien ça coûte
aujourd'hui de se loger à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines sachant qu'en
moyenne le logement ça représente plus
de 50% d'un budget d'un étudiant ses 55
% en ile-de-france pour se loger à 50
ans il faut prévoir globalement combien
que ça dépend de la taille du logement
là où on se loge exact les fourchettes
verts on est à peu près j'irais dans les
tarifs on a aussi des résidences
étudiantes qui sont plus anciennes que
d'autres ce qui fait qu'on peut arriver
entre 350 je vais dire au niveau au
niveau du plus bas et tout dépend de la
surface à 450 500 fonction aussi du fait
qu'on peut avoir des grands logements à
grande grande taille qu'on a soi des
soies des studios à 18 mètres carrés on
peut arriver jusqu'à 32 mètres carrés
donc voila tout dépend on est dans cette
fourchette à puis après on a les
résidences privées on est un tout petit
peu au dessus on est à 550 euros pour un
logement mais je dirais qu'aujourd'hui
l'offre sociale en tout cas à prix
social est suffisamment importante pour
permettre notamment aux personnes aux
étudiants les plus
ceux qui aujourd'hui en moins de moyens
de pouvoir de pouvoir se loger
et puis une autre solution existe elle
est peut-être moins connue et pourtant
elle permet de faire de réelles
économies c'est le logement
intergénérationnel
concrètement ça consiste en quoi
isabelle etienne c'est quoi le logement
intergénérationnel c'est pas forcément
connus je le disais alors c'est vrai que
par rapport à mes collègues on est sur
un concept assez innovant puisque le
logement intergénérationnel c'est
permettre à un étudiant 18-30 ans
grandement grand maximum d'être hébergé
chez un senior à partir de 60 ans et
après y'a pas de limites
mais surtout on a développé à
l'association trois différentes formules
de logement qui permette vraiment aux
jeunes d'être hébergés selon leurs
besoins leurs attentes et bien sûr leur
porte monnaie c'est à dire que le même
laurent belou pratiquement alors c'est
vrai quand j'entends des loyers 350 400
500 nous on connaît pas ça l'association
d'autres maximum dans les yvelines en
tous les cas c'est 350 380 grand maximum
et on a des étudiants qui sont logés
gratuitement en échange des offres leur
présence le soir et la nuit et la
personne âgée soit les étudiants sont
logés en échange de services rendus
et là il donne une centaine d'euros à la
personne âgée soit ils n'ont pas
disponibilité et là il paye 300 350 380
mais vraiment grand grand maximum quand
une fois seniors disponible c'est quoi
le contredisent bleus mangé avec la
personne quand ils sont la disponibilité
et la ce qu'on appelle en formule 2 la
wii est peu à peu près 100 enfin 800
euros là personnages et leur
disponibilité c'est soit pour des jeunes
qui vont être en licence en master ou un
peu de disponibilité dans l'après midi
ou alors une une soirée et là c'est
d'avoir des temps de convivialité c'est
2 2
avec la personne a un rendez vous voir
faire une expo pourquoi pas c'est fermer
les volets de ce world heroes 20 le
matin sortir la poubelle quelque chose
qu'on fait chez soi mais voilà on rend
service à la personne âgée et en échange
le jeune bénéficie vraiment d'un tarif
extrêmement intéressant et puis au delà
c'est de ce tarif l'association il est
écrit pour vraiment créer du lien entre
deux générations répondre aux
problématiques du logement étudiant
répondre à la solitude des seniors est
vraiment faire un pont entre ces deux
générations
et puis on parle souvent de la solitude
des seniors mais la solitude des
étudiants je pense que vous me
contredirait pas quand on est vraiment
là et les jeunes ils sont ravis d'être
installée chez un senior ils ont leur
chambre et partage
oui ou non la salle de bain la cuisine
bien évidemment et on a vraiment des
histoires si vous permettez
c'est comme une colocation est bien
normal il ya des rencontres il ya un
jour de dating pour voir si ça colle on
a les mêmes affinités c'est que nous
sommes en crise et enfin on rencontre
chaque étudiant on va visiter chaque
personne à son domicile
et puis le but c'est de créer l'alchimie
du binôme presque parfait puisque on
tend vers la perfection et je vous ai
apporté un livre qu'on vient de sortir
d'un l'occasion des 10 ans de
l'association où il ya 22 ans voilà dans
ce livre vous avez 22 binôme qui
illustre leur cohabitation dans des
conditions toutes différentes mais avec
vraiment des très bas très belle
histoire
est-ce que ça intéresse les jeunes est
ce que vous les jeunes sont plus en plus
intéressés par ce type de logement
est-ce que aussi ses conseillers à tout
le monde
concrètement ou alors faut avoir une eau
les jeunes sont pas faits pour la
cohabitation intergénérationnelle
certains vont vraiment apprécier d'être
indépendant des dans des foyers
d'autres ne vont pas forcément être
touché par la présence d'un ancien et
puis d'autres vont vouloir que ça à dire
moi je veux tu chez une personne âgée
parce que j'ai jamais vraiment connu mon
grand père ou ma grand mère et je
voudrais savoir quelle va être la
transmission je vais vivre avec un
ancien et cela via nano et cet après
midi entre ce matin et cet après midi
j'ai rencontré cinq étudiants en une
journée dont vous voyez il faut vraiment
essayer de caser tout le monde
donc là on a encore des possibilités
donc on
et ravi et puis toute l'année en fait
les seniors nous propose des chambres
pour x raisons on rentre des nouvelles
chambres donc on peut héberger des
jeunes en milieu d'année ceux qui sont
peut-être mal logés au démarrage ce qui
arrive en master en janvier ben voilà on
est vraiment open
paula de berlin florence cousin est ce
que ce type d'offre assez originale les
jeunes viennent vous voir vous en parle
vous pose des questions par exemple aux
cousins vous avez une information
jeunesse est ce qu'on vient se
renseigner sur le logement
intergénérationnel alors pas forcément
se monte à l'énorme spontanément mais si
justement nous qui éventuellement encore
une fois comme on prend le temps de
discuter avec le jeune de connaître sa
situation effectivement comme vous le
disiez c'est vrai que c'est pas fait
pour tout le monde c'est pas une formule
qui convient à tout le monde mais on
arrive à vérifier et puis on propose en
fait nous l'idée c'est d'avoir un panel
large propositions et après d'affiner
avec le jeune et de voir ce qui pourrait
lui convenir
donc après on incite à aller voir les
personnes en direct pour effectivement
prendre un contact et vérifier si c'est
la bonne formule pas de même nous on n'a
pas effectivement ce type de demande
on a plutôt par rapport comme vous
disiez ça c'est d'offrir un panel assez
variés on a des étudiants qui veulent
aller en résidence universitaire puis on
a des étudiants qui préfèrent aller soit
en changer l'habitant avec notamment à
travers le site localise soin d'aller de
vraiment avoir un coco familiale parce
que pour certains ils partent très jeune
très loin et donc le fait d'avoir cette
possibilité et cette variété d'offres de
logements aux étudiants je trouve ça
très intéressant parce que du coup ils
arrivent tous avec des histoires
différentes et avec des parents aussi
différents nous on les a rencontrés aux
formes logement et les parents qui sont
très préoccupés tester leurs enfants
dans une résidence universitaire au
milieu de plein d'étudiants qui vont
faire la fête
vous avez les étudiants en médecine qui
recherchent plutôt du calme donc voilà
on a la richesse de ce territoire c'est
aussi ça c'est de pouvoir offrir tout ça
quelle est la différence
concrètement entre une chambre chez
l'habitant et puis un logement
intergénérationnel
à part peut-être l'âge de la personne
chez qui l'on vit mais cela il ya l'âge
de
ya l'âge de la personne certes mais
comme je voulais dit l'association a été
créée pour vraiment faire du lien entre
ces deux générations et c'est vrai que
c'est important et moi j'ai beaucoup de
jeunes qui qui sont saisis par les
histoires des des personnes âgées avec
qui il vivait change beaucoup et du coup
il ya plus cette relation enfants
parents sont une génération et du coup
les liens sont assez on va dire détendu
et quand je vois tout ce qu'on nous
raconte quand on fait le bilan en fin
d'année ou encore en milieu d'année
quand on prend des nouvelle parce que
c'est bidon on les suit pendant l'année
au mois de décembre pour information on
fait ce qu'on appelle le dîner des
étudiants on reçoit tous les étudiants
de paris et d'île de france
on les reçoit tous à paris à dîner et je
peux dire c'est une soirée mais
absolument géniale où tous les étudiants
se découvre ce dessin mais on était
enfants nés en france en mai chez pacte
était logé par ensemble2générations et
puis il échange tous leur histoire on a
plein de petits mails en ce moment des
remerciements et pour nous dire vraiment
ça a été une belle année
et là vous parlais tout à l'heure des
étudiants en médecine moi j'en ai une
qui était logé mais pile en face de la
fac elle mettait trois minutes pour y
aller cocoon et par la dame qui prenait
soin d'elle deux soirs mais sans en
rajouter mais dix minutes de dialogue
après chacun est retourné en tous les
cas on étudiante repartez travailler et
c'était très rassurant pour les parents
une autre solution peut être à évoquer
avec vous la colocation est ce que là
aussi c'est un peu comme le logement
intergénérationnel est ce que c'est fait
pour tout le monde
est ce que ces pratiques est ce que
c'est vraiment moins chère laurence
cousant alors j'allais dire attention à
la colocation ce qu'on met derrière ce
mot parce que si on parle de
réglementation la colocation sens strict
du terme
il faut que chaque colocataire soit
inscrit sur le bail ne veut pas alors ce
qu'il ya une sorte de voile à 2
alors on a dû logement chez l'habitant
ou via plusieurs colocataires mais en
individuel dont il ya plusieurs versions
dont classés par ldc de bien faire
reformuler aux jeunes quel est son
attente et de ne pas le mettre en garde
mais en tout cas de lui dire attention à
telle et telle démarche de ce que vous
allez signer d'été quel type de contrat
vous allez signer parce que quand vous
faites de la contrée guillemets vrai
colocation donc chacun est sur le bail
si un jeune va faire un stage loin et
qui part il faut trouver un remplaçant
parce que trop non financièrement
parlant
il va y avoir une difficulté assez
rapidement d'accord mais si le bail est
rempli par exemple pour 4 personnes
c'est intéressant financièrement des 30
elles sont effectivement ça peut bien
sûr ça peut être lui saper ces valeurs
sont énormes élise possède pas cette
voie là la colocation est ce que c'est
quelque chose que vous faites vous par
exemple en pratique mais à la marge
parce que là il ya des craintes c'est
vrai que on peut craindre parfois en
colocation que ce soit un peu trop la
fête soit gênant pour les voisins j'ai
l'idée reçue qu'on peut avoir comme ça
des étudiants logram virtuellement sa
faire la fête aussi
mais en fait il ya de la demande pour
tous les publics et c'est ça qui est
intéressant je trouve dans ce qu'on
entend c'est que iliad multi une
multiplicité d'offres et dans tout ce
choix m'a chacun trouve son bonheur
est ce que dit madame par rapport
justement la convivialité tout ça mais
je trouve ça extrêmement intéressant
nous on pratique un peu aussi mais
sûrement pas la même échelle mais on
peut tirer intérêts des expériences des
autres pour les mettre en oeuvre aussi
chez nous une autre solution peut être
moins connus ou en tout cas qu'on ne
connaît pas comme ça pour pour les
jeunes c'est les logements pour jeunes
actifs ou les résidences sociales sont
accessibles aussi et notamment à saint
quentin pour les étudiants notamment il
ya effectivement ce qu'on appelle les
résidents 100 actifs comme on en parlait
tout à l'heure qui sont dessinés doit
soit aux jeunes salariés qui arrivent
sur notre territoire les apprentis du
coup et également les stagiaires parce
que là on parle des étudiants qui
arrivent au mois de septembre et puis
nous à partir d'avril on commence à
avoir des appels date de stagiaires qui
viennent faire leur stage sur une
entreprise du territoire et donc il ya
aussi cette offre là à pouvoir à pouvoir
auquel il faut répondre et donc qu'est
la résidence jeunes actifs ya les
résidences étudiantes qui permettent
aussi de répondre à ce besoin
rezidor jeunes d'actifs il faut avoir un
emploi tout simplement et donc soit être
apprenti souhaite jeunes salariés
que ça c'est aussi une solution laurence
cousin pour compléter je me permets
puisqu'on est en partenariat avec la
direction départementale de la cohésion
sociale depuis l'année dernière donc il
vit une information jeunesse et on va
essayer déployés au bureau et point
information jeunesse du département sur
ce qu'on appelle le contingent
préfectoral qui concerne des jeunes qui
ont un minimum de ressources
effectivement donc ils peuvent être
apprenti notamment et qui donc
concernées résidence jeunes actifs ou
des jeunes travailleurs donc ça c'est
vrai que ça peut être à un service
supplémentaire qu'on leur propose
et pour terminer aussi on a un service
jyloge qu'on appelle jyloge ou là on est
en relation les propriétaires des jeunes
quel que soit leur statut alors nous on
a été 40 ans on a eu 40 ans d'activité à
versailles donc c'est vrai que c'est
principalement sur le bassin de
versailles mais c'est aussi une
possibilité on a 35 logements
aujourd'hui qui sont proposés donc pour
les jeunes qui seraient intéressés en
tout cas on le voit sur le bassin de
saint quentin beaucoup d'offres beaucoup
de possibilités pour tout type de
logement pour tous les types d'étudiants
et toutes les attentes là je vais vous
poser une question maintenant parce
qu'on approche de l'émission de la fin
de l'émission une question pour les
spécialistes du logement que vous êtes
plus ou moins chacun est d'essayer de
voir quelle autre solution pour mettre
en place on sait que c'est difficile que
les politiques ont du mal généralement à
lancer les constructions à cette fois on
fait des plans plan 40 mille logements
lancés en 2013 mais qui est difficile à
mettre en place et les objectif
difficile à atteindre
quelle autre solution existe aujourd'hui
par exemple on sait quand on a celle m
aujourd'hui on peut pas prendre des
étudiants logés d'étudiants la chaîne m6
on peut alors je me suis trompé mais si
je me suis trompé folk qui permet à des
étudiants de moins de 30 ans d'être
hébergés chez les bailleurs sociaux
donc si c'est possible tout à fait bon
sous location est possible chez les
bailleurs sociaux
grâce à cette loi molle d'autres
solutions peut-être envisageable je sais
pas par exemple un plus grand soutien de
l'état quand il s'agit de de soutenir
des loyers qui sont peut-être difficile
à 50 ans ça va mais c'est vrai qu'à
paris ou en proche banlieue dizaine
d'années c'est abordable voilà
non mais je trouve que ça s'est
développé notamment pour les étudiants
dont il ya un effort qui a été quand
même fait je pense qu'il faut quand même
le signaler
après c'est peut-être pour tous les
jeunes puisque mon jeu encore une fois
et peut-être pour les jeunes
travailleurs ou vont parler de social de
voilà d'accessibilité mais il ya eu un
effort de fait quand même sur les
propositions en termes de logement
excusez moi je peux seulement pour les
primes aux salariés qui qui ont des
périodes d'essai de 3 mois 6 mois voire
renouvelables pour eux c'est très
difficile les arrive n'ont pas forcément
la possibilité dans une caution de la
part des parents donc là il faudrait que
l'état nous aide parce que c'est bien je
suis dans mon lit oui mais c'est vrai
que ces primes aux salariés ont vraiment
besoin d'être aidés pour démarrer un job
ce que quand on décroche un job c'est
quand même extrêmement important on a on
saute le pas dans la vie active il faut
vraiment les soutenir pour ceux du jeu
lego
ce qui est intéressant c'est
l'intergénérationnel en fait qu' il
faudrait peut-être réfléchir sur la
possibilité de réorganiser ses
financements pour sortir davantage de
projets parce que je pense qu'il ya une
vraie demande là dessus et c'est
intéressant en termes de cohabitation
des générations justement voilà deux
berlines peut-être oublié conclure au
moins rappelé le site internet
alors les sites internet pour saint
quentin en yvelines surtout à partie de
mon mieux une question ou une demande ne
pas hésiter à appeler l'agglomération
moi ce que je voulais rappeler c'était
qu'on a des droits de réservations ce
qui est important parce qu'on peut
positionner directement des candidats à
la fois les étudiants les apprentis et
les jeunes actifs
donc ça c'est une force de
l'agglomération et dire qu'on continue à
développer notamment les résidences
jeunes actifs pour les primes aux
salariés pour leur permettre d'arriver
d'être proche de leur travail puisque
c'est aussi un des enjeux de
l'agglomération c'est le rapprochement
habitat emploi et le premier celui des
jeunes actifs notamment
voilà merci à tous les quatre d'avoir
participé à cette émission et puis
d'avoir apporté des réponses et des
solutions sur cette problématique du
logement étudiant une émission que vous
pouvez
retrouver en podcast sur tv fil 78
points comme bonne soirée à tous